okay today I'm going to talk to you
about electronic configuration all the
electronic configuration means is how
are the electrons arranged in shells so
we're going to dive straight in and see
how to do this so let's imagine we were
looking at magnesium as a mass number of
24 an atomic number of 12 so remember
first of all this number here is the
atomic number that toss number of
protons it also tells the number of
electrons so I know magnesium has got 12
electrons and remember it's the protons
the neutrons that go in the nucleus
electrons that going shells around the
outside so how do they fit in so I
always start in the middle ship owner
shell on the inside and then work my way
out the only time I move to putting
electrons in a next show is when one
shell is complete so magnesium has got
12 electrons now in the first shell and
in the first shell only it can hold a
maximum of two electrons a maximum of
two electrons so for my magnesium has it
got two well yes it has so one two are
gonna go in the first show now for every
other shell apart from the first one it
can fit up to eight electrons so once it
has eight electrons in it it is full so
let's see I've put in two of these
twelve so far now when I do this I've
got a way of giving it just kind of
point of consistency so always
everything like this I've got two
already so I've got three four five six
seven eight nine ten now I can see I've
got ten electrons put in there in total
but this shell is now full because I
have one two three four five six seven
eight electrons in this yup select this
cell so I've got 10 in total I need two
more so then I move on to my next show
remember this shell can hold up to eight
electrons it's only the first one that
holds only two all of the other shells
can hold up to eight electrons so I've
got ten in here I've got two more to put
in
so one two so if I was asked to state
the electronic configuration of this so
sometimes the question says states the
electronic configuration all you need to
do is this you say how many electrons in
the first shell how many the electrons
in the second shell and how many in the
third so it would look like this
two eight soon so that is the electronic
configuration of magnesium and it's
drawn like this now let's see how that
relates to the periodic table remember
these numbers across here across the top
they are called group numbers so what
those numbers tell us magnesium is in
group two as we can see here what those
numbers tell us is how many electrons in
the outer shell turns in outer shell so
you can see here magnesium is in group
two how many electrons does it have an
its outer shell it's got two one two now
the other number that's a that can help
us out when it comes to electronic
configurations go down here now these
other period numbers and the period
number tells us the number of shells
so please remember that the first period
is along here so we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6
so we can double-check our electronic
configuration of magnesium because
magnesium is in period 1 2 3 it should
have three shells let's double check 1 2
3 so that's basically how electron
configurations work first of all you
need to check the atomic number to see
how many electrons you've got you then
always start in the middle shell and
work your way out the first show can
hold up to two electrons and every other
one could hold up to eight you only move
on to the next shell once one is
complete and just to help us to double
check our work the group number here
tell us how many electrons are in the
outer shell and the period number here
tells us how many shells in total and
that is electronic configuration thank
you